100 Euro sind 2000 türkische Lira 14.000
japanische Yen oder 1,6 Millionen
indonesische rupia das Geld ist überall
auf der Welt unterschiedlich viel wert
aber wie weit kommen wir real als
Touristen mit 100 € in Indien oder
Thailand Japan oder Brasilien der Türkei
oder Mexiko finden wir es gemeinsam
heraus viel Spaß mit 100 € in Kuba
Havana
natürlich starten wir auch in Kuba
Havanna mit einem ausgiebigen Frühstück
mit einem traditionellen Frühstück ich
bin einfach im Laden vorbei gelaufen
hier stehen einheimische deswegen werde
ich es ihm gleich tun um auch hier
frühstücken aber wie bezahlen wir ja
eigentlich 100 € sind laut Google 2500
kubanische Person dieser Wechselkurs
entspricht allerdings nicht der Realität
vor Ort haben wir gemerkt dass die
Währung realen noch mal sechs Mal
schwächer ist als im Internet zu finden
für 100 € bekommen wir also nicht 2500
sondern 15.000 Peso damit ist die
Währung so schwach wie seit 1990 nicht
mehr und ein durchschnittliches
Einkommen von 3.800 Personen im Monat
umgerechnet gerade einmal 25 € und 30
Cent
okay 25 kubanische Pesto für 5 dieser
ich weiß nicht genau was es ist ich habe
es einfach bestellt wir werden es gleich
herausfinden umgerechnet sowas wie 17
Cent also günstiger kommen wir wirklich
nicht weg
geil super fettig sowas wie Lauchzwiebel
drin vielleicht so ein bisschen die
kubanische Interpretation von
Quarkbällchen in salzig und in deutlich
fertiger bekommen haben wir das einfach
einen rechnungspapier dabei geht's
einfach nur darum irgendwie die Hände
nicht komplett fertig zu bekommen
schmeckt super gut unglaublicher Preis
richtig krass
[Musik]
wirklich richtig geil genauso habe ich
mir das vorgestellt einfach so ein
frühstücksverkauf aus dem Fenster raus
man hatte das Gefühl wir machen das aus
ihrer Wohnung dort wurde gelebt der
Bruder oder ein jüngerer Mann der im
Hintergrund unterwegs wart einfach da
die Wäsche gemacht und genau so hat es
geschmeckt als wäre es mit Liebe gemacht
und als hätte dieses Gericht wirklich
Tradition und wer über Jahre lang
verfeinert worden auch wenn es zu eins
der einfachen Gericht ist was aber in
den meisten Fällen wirklich die Besten
sind das Ding ist dieses kleine
Frühstück gerade eben am Straßenrand hat
natürlich nicht gereicht um uns komplett
satt zu bekommen jetzt einfach
weitergelaufen haben Kaffee gefunden all
das was ich hier seht kostet so ungefähr
acht neun Euro also dann befrucht hatte
und tot Gemüse zwei Drinks ein Smoothie
ein junger Drink ist also richtig
krassen
nach dem Frühstück ging es für uns auf
große Touri Reise durch Havanna mit
einer ganz bestimmten Person
guten morning Gustavo eigentlich
studierter Lehrer fährt aber seit Jahren
Taxi so wie es viele auch hochgebildete
Leute in Kuba tun weil sich im direkten
Kontakt mit Tourismus einfach mehr Geld
verdienen lässt Gustavo haben wir am Tag
vorher schon kennengelernt und er war
direkt super ehrlich mit uns hat uns
gesagt wo wir aufpassen müssen was für
Tourist Raps gibt und so weiter deswegen
habe ich gedacht er wäre der perfekte
Mann um uns für dieses 100 € in Kuba
Video einen Tag lang die Stadt zu zeigen
und uns in seinem Taxi herum zu fahren
natürlich Zigarren das number one Export
gut Kubas auf dem Weg dorthin sind wir
einige Umwege gefahren um direkt an
geschichtsträchtigen Orten vorbei zu
fahren nicht extra aussteigen zu müssen
aber einfach wie auf so einer Bus-Tour
Infos von Gustavo zu bekommen
wir sind jetzt im Laden vom weltbesten
Zigarrenroller und das sage ich nicht
nur einfach so er hat tatsächlich Kindes
World Records gewonnen ist bekannt auf
der ganzen Welt gerade in Amerika und
hier in Kuba hat alle wichtigen Personen
getroffen Pussy Kasseler Kairo 90 Meter
lange Zigarre gerollt aber abseits davon
auch
mega bekannt super krass das hier so
sehen zu können die Expertenmeinung der
der Leuten zu erfahren und natürlich
gleich auch Zigarren zu kaufen jetzt
können wir ihm tatsächlich noch bei der
Arbeit zu gucken ich weiß nicht ob man
die die er direkt hier heute noch kaufen
kann und ob die in irgendeiner Weise in
unserem 100 € Budget sind aber wir sehen
zumindest wirklich wie es gemacht wird
[Musik]
natürlich wollte ich mir auch nicht
nehmen lassen eine Zigarre zu rauchen
wenn man denn schon mal in Kuba ist dazu
aber später mehr
es ist Zeit für Mittagessen und da haben
wir uns was ganz Besonderes überlegt das
ist nämlich Teil unseres Deals viele der
Taxifahrer sind mit Shops und
Restaurants gepartnert bringen Touristen
rein und essen dann dafür kostenlos oder
bekommen irgendwie Kohle genau das
wussten wir und deswegen haben uns
entschieden dass Gustavo uns in genauso
einen Job bringt also wenn wir im extra
gesagt dass wir gerne so essen würden
dass wir quasi die kubanischen Preise
bezahlen das tun wir jetzt auch eine
Pizza kostet weniger als 3 € umgerechnet
das ist ein relativ einfaches schnelles
und Imbiss und ich bin gespannt was
jetzt gleich kommt beim Pizzen bestellt
mega gut und das wird dann unser
Mittagessen für heute
[Musik]
die Pizza war nicht besonders gut aber
wir haben ja auch genau noch so eine
experience gefragt und diese dann auch
bekommen in Kuba und auch auf allen
meinen anderen Reisen bin ich darauf
angewiesen öffentliche Netzwerke also
öffentliches Internet mit all meinen
Geräten in genau solchen Situationen in
Cafés und Restaurants zu benutzen und
weil das offensichtlich gefahren wird
wird dieses Video freundlicherweise von
nordvpn unterstützt deren Service über
die Videobeschreibung nur einen Klick
entfernt bei einer man in der mittec bei
der jemand in einem öffentlichen
Netzwerk alle eure Daten klauen könnte
um beispielsweise eure ganzen Social
Media Accounts zu kapern werdet ihr mit
nordvpn sicher dass ich eure
datenverschlüsseln egal ob das Netzwerk
sicher ist oder nicht allgemein ist
nordvpn essentiell um dauerhaft sichere
Surfen zu garantieren und euch weniger
angreifbar für schädliche Software und
Mehl zu machen das Beste dank Nord links
könnt ihr das mit gleich bleibender
Geschwindigkeit tun und weiter schneller
surfen außerdem habt ihr natürlich
weiterhin Zugriff auf alle eure
Lieblingsinhalte auch wenn sie in eurem
Land eigentlich gar nicht verfügbar sind
oder sogar die Möglichkeit Streaming
Dienste zu einem günstigeren Preis zu
bekommen check das ganze über den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung unter
www.nordvpn.com/
VPN ab um euch den exklusiven Deal zu
sichern und dank der 30 Tage Geld zurück
Garantie könnt ihr das ganze komplett
risikofrei testen also vielen Dank an
nordvpn die dieses Video möglich machen
checkt das Angebot über den ersten Link
in der Videobeschreibung ab und euch
viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
kostenpunkt für den gesamten Tag
Stadtführung und Taxi inklusive 3000
Pesto pro Person kuba hat eine ziemlich
durchwachsene Geschichte all das haben
wir auf der Tour mit Gustavo erfahren
wenn ich das wirklich interessiert Check
die Links in der Videobeschreibung ab es
gibt super gute Videos und Dokus dazu
ist zu Ende ich hoffe ich konnte euch
das in irgendeiner Weise näher bringen
natürlich kann ich euch nicht von allem
erzählen aber kuba hat historisch so
viel zu bieten dass mir das an diesem
Standort jetzt tatsächlich einfach mal
wichtig war nicht wirklich darüber zu
informieren auch wenn das ansonsten nie
in meinem Interessengebiet fällt jetzt
geht es für uns in den Kunstmarkt bei
dem ist angeblich so mit die günstigste
Kunst auf der ganzen Welt geben soll und
trotzdem in höchster Qualität wir haben
hardshellkoffer dabei wir können die
Sachen mitnehmen und unser Budget lässt
es tatsächlich auch noch zu dass wir uns
selber unseren Freunden noch mehr
mitbringen als wir schon mit den
Zigarren tun also jetzt rein und Kunst
kaufen
[Musik]
ja also unheimlich schade genau das was
ich mir nicht erhofft hatte es im
Prinzip eine dieser Markthallen in der
jeder das gleiche hat man hat das Gefühl
am Anfang der Woche kommt ein LKW lädt
bei allen genau die gleiche unnötige
Scheiße ab also wirklich mega nervig und
das hier ist wirklich einfach nur wieder
der letzte Müllhaufen absolut keine
Empfehlung hinzugehen auch wenn es
kostenlos ist
gerade noch komplett abgefuckt und im
Hintergrund in der Aufnahme sieht man
sogar das Schild indem man sehen kann
zweiter Stock für Künstler jetzt sind
wir auf dem Weg dahin was wir die ganze
Zeit gesucht haben also wenn ihr mal
hier sein sollte es gibt zwei Stockwerke
wir wussten nicht dass da ist das hier
sieht schon deutlich besser aus
[Musik]
viel entspannter hier man wird nicht die
ganze Zeit voll gelabert und dann hat
das Gefühl die Sachen sind hier wirklich
von den einzelnen Künstlern deutlich
entspannter deutlich schönere Sachen ein
absoluter Traum genau das wofür wir
eigentlich bekommen haben
unsere Unterkunft in Kuba ihr hört es
schon am Hals es ist unglaublich riesige
Räume hohe Decken Altstadt Altbau es ist
man fühlt sich wirklich in weiß ich
nicht 500 Jahre zurückversetzt ich meine
schaut euch das mal an
das Ziel ist der Eingang also hier
passiert eigentlich nicht was passiert
gar nichts aus diesem Eingangsbereich
geht es in einem weiteren quasi den
Hinterhof von dem aus die ganzen
verschiedenen Zimmer das airbnbs
Weggehen
sieht unglaublich nice aus ich kann euch
sagen dass mich der Preis völlig
überrascht hat also klar hier ist super
viel angepasst die Leute probieren einen
auch so ein bisschen abzuziehen und so
weiter diese Unterkunft allerdings hat
mich richtig aus den Socken gehauen 31
$ pro Nacht für zwei Personen für ein
komplettes Zimmer in dieser Kulisse
wirklich völlig verrückt und wir schauen
uns jetzt an wie das Zimmer an sich so
aussieht wir haben nicht nur
eingeschossen sondern zwei Geschosse für
31,00
Minibar absolut fein top und von da geht
es nicht nur hier in die zweite Etage
die wir uns gleich anschauen sondern
auch ins Badezimmer es sieht aus als
wäre es überall mega dunkel das hat auch
seinen Sinn und Zweck damit es hier
einfach nicht zu heiß wird basic
Waschbecken basic Toilette basic Dusche
alles was man braucht und vor allem eine
Menge Platz und von hier geht es wieder
raus über die Treppe in den zweiten
Stock in dem uns eigentlich nichts
erwartet außer das Bett was aber super
kommt alles super schick aus hier riecht
es nicht verschimmelt ist nicht durch
gewohnt wir haben eine Klimaanlage für
den Preis ist das hier wirklich
unschlagbar und ich glaube Preis
leistungsmäßig das Beste was jemals
gebucht habe
also ja klar wir sind jetzt heute morgen
den ganzen Tag am Taxi rumgefahren das
ist aber eigentlich nicht der schnellste
und günstigste Weg um sich in Havanna zu
bewegen eigentlich sind es genau diese
Teile
elektrische angetrieben einfach als
Fahrrad getreten mit Motor und Benzin
egal in welchem Wege die fahren hier zu
Haupt rum man wird die ganze Zeit
angelabert und genau damit machen wir
uns jetzt auch auf dem Weg
[Musik]
mit Mucke mit Musikbox mit allen
verschiedenen Antrieben also ist
wirklich hier mit Rückspiegel mit allem
alles was jemals irgendwo fahrbereit war
wird hier gefahren bis zum bitteren Ende
also richtig geil
[Musik]
das ist der eigentliche Weg sich hier in
der Stadt zu bewegen der auch von den
Einheimischen benutzt wird und auch hier
zahlen wir natürlich drüber aber für die
10 15 Minuten Fahrt die das jetzt gerade
waren haben wir so ungefähr 1 € 20
bezahlt also 200 Pesto das ist halt
nicht
wir sind in der Altstadt von Kuba diese
ganzen Gebäude hier in der Abendsonne es
ist wirklich unglaublich glaube es gibt
keine andere Stadt die nur im Ansatz so
aussieht so eine Historie hat man merkt
den europäischen Einfluss krass und ich
fühle mich hier super wohl also im
Vergleich zu Panama wo wir vorher waren
habe ich hier auch nicht ein einziges
Mal Schiss gehabt egal in welcher Straße
wir zu egal welche Uhrzeit unterwegs
waren das ist hier einfach was anderes
und ich finde sie richtig geil ich meine
schaut euch das mal an
going
hi how much is one
okay ähm
[Musik]
du weißt du bist in gefährlich
egal in welchem Land du jemals so etwas
siehst nimm die Beine in die Hand und
lauf wir laufen jetzt nicht wir gehen
jetzt einfach genau hier in Restaurant
hallo
[Musik]
der Laden in dem wir sind ist so so eine
gute Tourist Trapp dass der Typ der
draußen sich darum kümmert dass genug
Touris in den Laden kommen und gestern
schon angesprochen hat wie gesagt haben
ja ja wir kommen morgen vorbei ja uns
heute wieder angesprochen hat und uns
quasi darauf festgenagelt hat dass wir
ihm gestern eine Notlüge mitgegeben
haben super sympathisch aber und jetzt
haben wir die Karte gerade bekommen und
die Preise sind ungefähr drei oder
viermal so hoch wie das was wir sonst
hier so erlebt haben also eine Pizza er
erinnert euch heute Mittag ungefähr 400
weiß auch nicht die allerbeste Qualität
hier aber die günstigste 1.500 also so
10 € anstatt 4 und das geht hoch bis auf
zweieinhalb Tausend 3000 Personen wo man
dann ganz schnell bei ungefähr 20 €.
unser Essen ist gekommen viele der
Preise stehen gar nicht auf der Karte
ich musste sie erfragen ich musste
tatsächlich auch bei dem Fisch den ich
zur Hauptspeise genommen habe die
Beilagen dahin verhandeln also sie hat
gesagt ja nicht nur der Fischen habe ich
gesagt genau King bis sie dann
irgendwann tatsächlich den Reis und das
Gemüse rausgerückt hat wie viel am Ende
jetzt wirklich hier auf der Rechnung
stehen wird kann ich noch nicht sagen
und testen das ganze jetzt mal und
werden schauen wie selber abgezogen
wurde eins kann ich schon mal sagen die
denken dass die uns die ganze Zeit
abziehen und wir bezahlen auch deutlich
mehr als übereinander aber das
Hauptgericht kostet 12 €. also wir sind
immer noch völlig normalen deutschen
Rahmen und ähm wer zuletzt lach lacht am
besten
[Musik]
7100 geben einfach 7500
nach dem Essen ging es für uns noch in
eine Bar 40 Jahre und zwei Cocktails
habe ich 1400 Peso also ca 9,30 €
gezahlt bei den Drinks hatte ich genug
Zeit um Kuba ins Visa lohnt sich eine
Reiser Ranking einzurenken folgende
Punkte für Kuba Preis Anreise zwei von
fünf Punkten da ist noch mal teurer ist
dorthin zu kommen als Panama City und
ihr mit mindestens 600 € für hin und
Rückflug rechnen müssen 100 € Budget
ganz klar fünf Punkte mehr geht fast
nicht gerade die Unterkunft für 15 € war
schon krass Location 4 von 5 Havanna war
schon super außerdem liegt Kuba
natürlich in der Karibik und ihr könnt
weiße Strände und blaues Wasser haben
wenn ihr wollt fun factor 3 von 5
wohlfühl Faktor 4 von 5 die Leute waren
sehr korrekt und haben einen zumindest
charmant abgezogen und niemand war
aufdringlich oder so und noch mal hin
Faktor sind drei von fünf einfach so 21
von 30 Punkten für Kuba und damit vor
Panama und hinter New York City vergesst
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren und mich
in den Kommentaren wissen zu lassen von
wo ihr noch sein Video sehen wollt macht
es gut ciao